SWIRLIC, AND SCOTT JENNINGS,
FORMER SPECIAL ASSISTANT TO
FORMER PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH.
I'M SO GLAD THAT YOU ALL ARE
HERE.
I HAVE TO ASK -- WHY ARE YOU
ALREADY SMIRKING?
WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW?
GO AHEAD.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION?
>> TO THE STUDENT LOAN DEBACLE?
THE DISGRACE --
>> IT'S A DEBACLE?
>> WHERE DO I START?
IT'S INFLATIONARY.
IT'S ILLEGAL.
IT'S IMMORAL.
IT'S IRRATIONAL.
IT'S IDIOTIC.
IT'S INEQUITABLE, AND THOSE ARE
JUST THINGS THAT START WITH THE
LETTER "I."
I COULD GO ON TO OTHER LETTERS
OF THE ALPHABET.
I THINK WHAT HE DID TODAY IS A
DIRECT REACTION TO THE FACT THAT
YOUNG DEMOCRATS IN ALL THE
POLLING WE'VE SEEN HATE JOE
BIDEN.
AND HE'S SENDING THEM ALL A
$10,000 CHECK IN AN EFFORT TO
BUY HIS SUPPORT.
EVEN NANCY PELOSI STATED ON THE
RECORD UNEQUIVOCALLY THAT THIS
IS ILLEGAL, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES DOES NOT HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DO THIS.
AND THE FINAL QUESTION IS, THERE
IS NO WORLD WHERE YOU WOULD
CONSIDER THIS TO BE FAIR.
WHAT MAKES THIS DEBT MORE
RIGHTEOUS THAN THE SMALL PLUMBER
WHO TOOK OUT A LOAN TO BUY A NEW
VAN OR THE PERSON WHO GOT A
MORTGAGE OR THE PERSON WHO GOT A
LOAN TO BUY A CAR SO THEY COULD
DRIVE THEMSELVES BACK AND FORTH
TO WORK?
OR WHAT MAKES IT FAIR TO THE
PERSON WHO PAID OFF THEIR DEBTS,
TO THE PARENT WHO JUST WROTE THE
LAST CHECK FOR THEIR SON OR
DAUGHTER TO GO TO COLLEGE?
THERE'S NO WORLD IN WHICH THIS
ISN'T A CYNICAL, POLITICAL PLOY
BY AN ELDERLY PRESIDENT TRYING
TO BUY THE VOTES OF THE YOUNGEST
PEOPLE IN HIS --
>> MARIA KOR DOE NA JUST MOVED
HER PHONE AWAY FROM YOU.
>> I HOPE SHE WAS RECORDING IT.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WERE
GOING TO THROW IT.
>> SHOCKER THAT A REPUBLICAN
WOULD BE AGAINST SOMETHING A
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT IS DOING
THAT IS WILDLY POPULAR AT A TIME
WHEN DEMOCRATS ARE GAINING
MOMENTUM GOING INTO THE MIDTERM
ELECTION SHOWING IT IS YET
ANOTHER PROMISE KEPT BY THIS
PRESIDENT.
AND BY THE WAY, IT WAS A PROMISE
HE MADE TO VOTERS, TO
CONSTITUENTS, NOT JUST YOUNG
PEOPLE, BUT, YES, YOUNG PEOPLE
DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
HE DIDN'T JUST COME UP WITH
THIS.
AND BY THE WAY, IT'S RICH THAT
REPUBLICANS ARE TALKING ABOUT
FAIRNESS WHEN THEY HAVE PASSED
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN CORPORATE TAX CUTS, IN
CORPORATE SOCIALISM, AND NOW
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT FAIRNESS?
GIVE ME AN EFFing BREAK.
>> THINK ABOUT THAT.
GOOD CENSORSHIP -- I LIKE THAT.
HE HAD THE LETTER I.
YOU HAD THE LETTER F.
WE'RE NOT THERE YET.
BUT ON THE POINT -- WE DO HAVE
OTHER FORGIVENESS PROGRAMS,
RIGHT?
>> TRUE.
>> THIS IS NOT TOTALLY NOVEL IN
THE IDEA THAT THIS DEBT, AS
SCOTT MENTIONED, BEING SO
RIGHTEOUS.
THERE ARE SOME GENERATIONS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BENEFIT.
WHERE DO YOU COME OUT ON THIS?
>> SO, I AGREE WITH ONE POINT
THAT YOU MADE, MARIA, AND ONE
POINT THAT YOU MADE, SCOTT.
>> THAT'S VERY DIPLOMATIC.
THAT WAS VERY DIPLOMATIC.
>> LOOK, YOU'RE RIGHT.
THIS KIND OF DEBT IS NOT MORE
RIGHTEOUS THAN A SMALL BUSINESS
LOAN.
ONE DIFFERENCE THOUGH, SMALL
BUSINESS LOAN, OTHER KINDS OF
PERSONAL DEBT, YOU CAN DISCHARGE
IN BANKRUPTCY.
YOU CAN'T DISCHARGE THIS IN
BANKRUPTCY.
TREASURY SECRETARY SUMMERS THE
OTHER DAY OPPOSED DOING THAT
INSTEAD OF THIS.
THIS IS DEBT THAT PEOPLE ARE
REALLY DRAGGING ALONG.
THE OTHER THING ABOUT THIS IS
THAT WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
POLICY, SCOTT, YOU'VE GOT TO
REMEMBER THAT EVERY -- JUST AS
LAURA SAID, EVERY SORT OF GIVE
AWAY, IF YOU WILL, IS A GIVE
AWAY TO SOMEBODY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP GAVE MONEY TO
FARMERS, WHO VOTED FOR HIM TO DO
A TRADE WAR WITH CHINA.
AND THEN HE SUBSIDIZED THE TRADE
WAR BY SUBSIDIZING THEIR
PRODUCTS THAT CHINA WAS PUTTING
TARIFFS ON.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID THE 2017 TAX
CUT, AND THAT WAS A GIVE AWAY IN
A LOT OF PEOPLE'S EYES TO
WEALTHIER AMERICANS.
>> WHO --
>> BEFORE I -- HOLD ON.
BEFORE WE GET THERE -- ZBLIETS A
TENGS.
>> BEFORE WE GET THERE -- THIS
WILL INFUSE THE CONVERSATION
BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
EQUITY AND FAIRNESS.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN ABOUT EQUITY AND FAIRNESS.
I WANT TO TAKE A PAUSE.
WE MENTIONED THE STUDENT DEBT
PLAN.
I WANT TO LOOK AT WHO IT WILL
ACTUALLY IMPACT.
GOING TO HELP EASE THE PAIN IN
COMMUNITIES MOST HAMPERED BY
DEBT, RACIAL MINORITIES.
BUT NAACP, TO A DIFFERENT POINT,
MAY SAY IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
THEY SAY, QUOTE, CANCELLING JUST
$10,000 OF DEBT IS LIKE POURING
A BUCKET OF ICE WATER ON A
FOREST FIRE.
IT HARDLY ACHIEVES ANYTHING,
ONLY MAKING A MERE DENT IN THE
PROBLEM.
AND WE KNOW THE PROBLEM IS VAST.
YOU HAVE FEDERAL STUDENT LOAN
DEBT IN THE U.S. AROUND
$1.6 TRILLION.
IT WAS A MODEL FROM THE URBAN
INSTITUTE THAT SHOWED THAT 62%
OF THE CANCELLED STUDENT LOAN
DOLLARS WOULD GO TO WHITE
BORROWERS, VERSUS THE 25% THAT
WOULD GO TOWARD BLACK BORROWERS,
8% FOR HISPANIC BORROWERS.
LOOK A LITTLE CLOSER, AND IT'S
BLACK WOMEN -- I'M POINTING AT
MYSELF -- WHO HOLD THE MAJORITY
OF STUDENT DEBT.
SHOULDN'T COME AS A SURPRISE,
CONSIDERING MESSAGES, WELL, LIKE
THIS.
>> A COLLEGE MAN, I GOT ME A
COLLEGE MAN.
>> MA, THIS LETTER JUST MEANS I
GOT ACCEPTED.
IT DOESN'T MEAN WE CAN AFFORD
IT.
>> NONSENSE.
IT MEANS YOU'RE SMART, YOU
WORKED FOR IT, AND YOU DESERVE
IT.
HON NEERKS IT'S YOUR CHANCE, AND
WE'RE GOING TO GET YOU ON THAT
BUS SOMEHOW.
>> YOU'RE THE FIRST IN THIS
FAMILY TO GET INTO COLLEGE.
>> I'M SO PROUD OF YOU.
>> I CAN'T GO, CAN I?
>> JUST CAN'T AFFORD TO SEND
YOU.
>> I REMEMBER ADS LIKE THAT WHEN
THEY WERE PLAYING, AND THEY
WOULD PLAY ALL THE TIME AND BE
REALLY FOMENTED IN THE MINDS OF
SO MANY PEOPLE.
AND YET WE SEE AMERICANS, PEOPLE
OF COLOR, WHO MUST SPEND WAY
MORE FOR A CHANCE AT THE
AMERICAN DREAM.
ANALYSIS SHOWED THAT BLACK
COLLEGE GRADUATES OWE $7,400
MORE, JUST ON AVERAGE, THAN
THEIR WHITE PEERS.
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT INTEREST AND
GRADUATE SCHOOL BORROWING,
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT BLACK
GRADUATES HOLDING NEARLY $53,000
IN STUDENT LOAN DEBT AFTER
GRADUATING, ALMOST TWICE AS MUCH
AS THEIR WHITE COUNTERPARTS.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT FAIRNESS,
RIGHT?
WE KNOW AT TIMES WE
COMPARTMENTALIZE WHEN EQUITY
OUGHT TO BE DULLED OUT.
IT'S PART OF THE CONVERSATION.
DOES IT CHANGE OR INFLUENCE YOU
AT ALL?
ZBLING SOME OF THESE THINGS ARE
EXTREMELY FAIR.
I THINK EVERY TIME YOU PEEL A
LAYER BACK LIKE YOU JUST DID ON
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHITE
BORROWERS AND AFRICAN AMERICAN
BORROWERS, YOU SEE HOW LITTLE
THOUGHT IS PUT INTO THIS.
BUT THE PART OF THE BASE JOE
BIDEN IS WORRIED ABOUT ARE THE
YOUNG, WHITE, GENDER STUDIES
MAJORS WHO ARE SO UNHAPPY WITH
HIM.
NONE OF THEM WANT TO SUPPORT HIM
FOR PRESIDENT AGAIN.
THAT IS WHO HE IS WRITING A
CHECK TO TODAY.
IT IS TAKING FOR GRANTED
EVERYBODY YOU JUST MENTIONED.
AND I CAN'T BELIEVE I'M THE ONLY
PERSON AT THIS TABLE WHO ISN'T
MORE BOTHERED BY THE FACT THAT
THIS IS TOTALLY ILLEGAL.
THERE IS NO AUTHORITY FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO DO THIS AT ALL.
AND CHUCK SCHUMER, THE SENATE
DEMOCRAT LEADER SAID TODAY, WITH
THE FLICK OF A PEN, JOE BIDEN
HAS GOT -- WHY EVEN HAVE A
CONGRESS?
WHERE IS THE COEQUAL OR MORE
IMPORTANT BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT
IN ALL OF THIS?
>> BECAUSE FOR SO LONG CONGRESS,
REPUBLICANS SPECIFICALLY, HAVE
SAID NO ON ANY KIND OF POLICY
THAT WOULD GIVE ANY KIND OF
EQUITY TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO NEED IT THE
MOST.
AND I CAN IT'S INSULTING, SCOTT,
THAT YOU SAY THAT THIS POLICY
WILL NOT HELP BLACK STUDENTS,
WILL NOT HELP LATINO STUDENTS --
>> I DIDN'T.
SHE SAID IT.
I DIDN'T SAY IT.
SHE LAID IT OUT.
>> I DIDN'T SAY IT.
>> YOU JUST GAVE A VERY
COMPELLING REPORT.
>> I GAVE A REPORT OF WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> YOU SAID THIS WOULD ONLY HELP
WHITE STUDENTS THAT ARE STUDYING
GENDER STUDIES, WHATEVER THAT
MEANS.
I DON'T KNOW.
IT SOUNDS INULT ISSING.
>> IT IS INSULTING.
I'M INSULTING.
>> BY GENDER STUDIES?
>> PEOPLE IN MY COMMUNITY,
PEOPLE IN LAURA'S COMMUNITY,
PEOPLE IN MANY COMMUNITIES,
INCLUDING WHITE PEOPLE, WILL
BENEFIT FROM THIS.
THAT'S WHY IT IS EQUITABLE.
LAURA, IS IT THE BE ALL AND END
ALL?
NO.
BUT IT WILL BE A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
WE NEED TO REFORM THE WAY THAT
WE SEND OUR STUDENTS TO SCHOOL.
WHEN MY PARENTS BROUGHT US TO
THIS COUNTRY, IT WAS BECAUSE WE
HAD THIS DREAM OF BEING ABLE TO
DO ANYTHING YOU WANTED IF YOU
STUDIED HARD, IF YOU PLAYED BY
THE RULES.
AND MY PARENTS WERE ABLE TO SEND
US TO COLLEGE BECAUSE OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES IN THIS COUNTRY.
I WANT EVERYONE TO HAVE THAT.
AND APPARENTLY REPUBLICANS
DON'T.
>> WELL, GO AHEAD.
>> I WAS GOING TO QUICKLY SAY, I
DIDN'T GET TO SAY WHY I AGREED
WITH MARIA.
THIS WAS NOT A SURPRISE.
BIDEN AND OTHER DEMOCRATS
CAMPAIGNED ON THIS.
IT MAY GO DOWN IN COURT IN SOME
OF THE WAYS THINGS LIKE
PRESIDENT OBAMA EXECUTIVE
ORDERED.
SO, I DON'T THINK YOU'RE WRONG
THERE.
BUT THIS WAS SOMETHING DEMOCRATS
CAMPAIGNED ON.
IT WAS NOT A SECRET.
AND BIDEN IS BRINGING IT OUT AT
A TIME WHEN HE'S ON A LITTLE BIT
OF A HOT STREAK.
>> IT IS A PROMISE --
>> I AGREE HE CAMPAIGNED ON IT.
I GUESS I COULD CAMPAIGN ON ALL
SORT OF ILLEGAL THINGS, IT
DOESN'T MATTER.
THERE'S NOTHING LEGAL OR PROPER
OR GOOD POLICY ABOUT IT.
IT'S PURE POLITICS.
>> ONE OF THE REASONS THEY HAVE
SAID THEY DID THIS IS BECAUSE OF
THE IMPA